le versant Est de Montserrat n'a pas été
épargné par le volcan malgré
l'interdiction de pénétrer sur cette
zone dangereuse certains comme ma paille
ressentent le besoin d'y retourner
sur toute cette zone il y avait des
terres agricoles
ont cultivé des légumes des concombres
des tomates des choux des melons du maïs
des haricots
c'était une immense zone de culture qui
s'étendait sur cette vaste plaine
ici le sol était très riche tout poussé
on pouvait se nourrir on était
autosuffisant on ne dépendait pas de la
Dominique
c'est là que beaucoup de mes amis et moi
avons grandi on passait ici tout notre
temps libre et c'est ici qu'on a tous
appris à nager dans l'océan Atlantique
l'eau était toujours très agitée j'ai
adoré mon enfance ici
les gens qui sont restés sont des
irréductibles ils n'ont pas voulu
quitter leur maison
ils n'ont pas voulu quitter leur terre
leur racine
3000 résilients sur les 12000 personnes
que comptait mon serra sont restés sur
l'île après l'éruption dramatique de
[Musique]
ils ont rebâti au nord les écoles les
commerces
[Musique]
et vivent toujours au rythme de
l'activité de la Montagne de Feu
[Musique]
et des informations volcanologiques
relayées par la radiologie locale
bonjour je suis rose willoc et ce sont
les news du matin en partenariat avec la
BBC
depuis 40 ans
rose willoc informe ses concitoyens sur
les ondes
[Musique]
évidemment quand cette catastrophe
naturelle est arrivée j'étais au bon
endroit au bon moment on a fait ce qu'il
fallait informer les gens les gens de
Montserrat mais aussi à l'étranger la
radio est essentielle ici pas simplement
à Montserrat mais dans toute la Caraïbe
la télévision c'est plus pour les pays
développés comme les Etats-Unis la radio
ce n'est pas cher et vous pouvez en
avoir dans toutes les pièces et il y a
quelque chose d'instantané avec ce média
et ça c'est bien pour nous